OpenClaw just dropped its new free
update for March the 2nd and it's
packed. We're talking AI that can now
read your PDFs instantly. AI agents that
can talk to each other and hand off
tasks without you lifting a finger.
Realtime responses stream live so it
actually feels like conversation inside
Telegram. Plus over 100 security fixes
so your setup is better than before.
This is not an upgrade. This is a
completely different tool to how it
feels like last week. And here's the
craziest part. It's completely free. you
can get updated and set this up today.
We're going to look at every single one
of these new features together right now
live so you can see exactly what this
thing can do and whether it actually
lives up to the hype. If you've been
waiting for one AI tool to run your
entire life, this might be it. Let's
find out. So, we're going to get
straight into this. You can see the
update right here and this is the
update. Now, the first thing to note
here is the Telegram um streaming
example of the messages, right? So, you
can see the messages and how it comes in
in real time uh like this inside the
video. So, if you want to see the full
change log, here are all the new updates
like you can see. So, a bunch of
changes, a heavy, heavy list of changes
as you can see. There must be what, at
least 50 different changes added to
this. And there's a bunch of new updates
here. Now, if you want to update this
automatically, what you can do is just
go to your config file here, scroll down
inside open claw if you've got this
running, and then you're going to make
sure that you have auto update enabled
over here. Auto update. Right. Now, once
you've done that, we're going to go over
to the chat and we're going to click
update now. You can see the notification
here. So, it says the um 2nd of March
update is currently running the first of
March update. So, we need to update.
We're going to on that update now
button. Sometimes this breaks, sometimes
it doesn't work. We're going to figure
out what happens together and test it
out and we'll see how it performs. So,
it's beginning to update now. Sometimes
the gateway breaks. I will warn you now.
But if it does, it's okay cuz I'll show
you exactly how to fix it along the way
and how to get this working. Now, let's
talk about the update whilst it's
beginning to auto update itself. Um, and
we'll talk you through some of the
changes and how it happens. So, if
you've never heard of OpenClaw before,
I'll keep this short, but you're about
to be very happy on what you stumbled
on. This free tool got one of its
biggest updates ever. Um, and it's
basically like a really powerful sort of
AI that runs locally on your laptop. And
it lets you, for example, connect AI
systems, automate tasks, build custom
workflows, and do all of this. And it's
completely free and open source to use.
You can even connect it to, for example,
uh, OAMA or Quen 3.5 and run this
locally without any API costs as well,
which is pretty awesome. So,
once we've done this, we can see it.
Now, I'm just going to check the
terminal and make sure that it's
working. Check the logs inside the
terminal. When I actually click update
now, it doesn't seem to be, but let's
see if it's working. Now, I'm just going
to say, are you working? Sometimes it
just takes a little while to respond.
So, I'm going to see what happens uh
when we click, are you working? It might
have just broken again. So, let's test
it out. And then let's talk about what
changed in the meantime. So, now you get
this sort of live uh messages inside
Telegram, right? So, what that means is
that you get the responses instantly and
you can see them as they go along inside
the chat, which is pretty cool. And then
also
you can basically when your AI responds
inside Telegram, the text now appears
word by word in real time just like
watching someone type. So here's the
example, right? So this is an example of
an open claw responding and someone said
like send me a 30 line haiku and then it
started to produce the haiku in real
time right here. Right? It's pretty cool
because then you don't have to wait for
the whole message to load. You just get
it um good to go. Right? And so if we go
back inside the chat now, I'm just going
to say, are you updated to the latest
version? Because you can see already
that it's it's getting buggy inside the
chat here. So if we click on update now,
it just it clicks updating and then
stops working, right? Um, so I'm going
to see what it responds with now and
just make sure it is working on the
right version. If not, we might have to
run a terminal command to get it
running. Um, or we could just uninstall
it and then reinstall it again using the
newest updates as well. Let's see what
we got inside the chats here. So, Sakura
says, "What is the best model to run
locally and get results?" So, I would
recommend checking out Olama Quinn 3.5.
GLM 4.7 Flash is a cloud model, but it
runs locally with Oama, if that makes
sense. So, it runs via OAM, but it's a
cloud API. But if you want like a fully
fully local way of running OpenC, then
you can use Olama 3.5. I actually did a
video on it earlier this morning and
created a full guide. You can check that
out inside the AI profit boardroom. So
if you go to the open claw plus aquen
3.5 plus alarm just dropped some smaller
models that are faster to run locally
but still very powerful and those were
just dropped a few hours ago. So I've
got a full guide and tutorial on how to
set that up as you can see right here
inside the air profit boarding. So let's
go back to the update details now and if
we go back to open claw
you can see that it says we're actually
ahead. So, it is running the March the
2nd release. There does seem to be some
sort of bug inside the update section.
So, like when I click this, it doesn't
respond. But you can see here that it's
running the March the 2nd update, which
is great. So, it's good to go, right?
I'm just going to make sure. Are you I'm
going to say, are you running? Let's
just copy this. Are you running the
update? If not, can you run can you
update to the
version the the March the second
version. So let's just see what it does
in a second. If not, what I'm going to
do is just I'm going to grab the URL
from the change log at the top here and
then we'll plug that back into OpenCL.
So now it's beginning to check with open
claw to see whether it's done or not. In
the meantime, let me talk you through
what the other updates are. Right. So,
one of the other cool things here is ACP
agents, sub agents are now on by
default. Now, if you're wondering what
ACP is, ACP stands for agent
communication protocol. It's like a
walkie-talkie system that lets multiple
AI agents talk to each other and hand
off tasks. Now, bear in mind with ACP,
you can even, for example, um you can
even use something like uh Claude Code
with ACP if you've never seen that
before. And this is switched on by
default. Now, I'm sure you would have to
allow permissions to get it using claude
code, but you can see an example of how
this works. And this means it can
basically run like claude code locally
for you and a bunch of other sub aents,
right? So, your agents can build teams,
work together, um, spawn sub aents, that
sort of thing, right? So, if you're
wondering, okay, what changed? Well,
previously you had to manually turn this
feature on. Now, it's enabled
automatically when you set up Open Claw.
So, you could have like one AI agent
that handles custom questions, another
one that handles scheduling. With ACP,
they now automatically pass tasks to
each other without you having to be
middleman, right? So ACP dispatch now
defaults to enable. Um, and if you're
upgrading from the older version and you
specifically don't want agents talking
to each other, you can manually turn
this off with this command right here as
you can see. So let's go back to open
claw. See what we're doing. And it's
like, yeah, your open claw is already on
the 2nd of March. So this is interesting
because the button at the top doesn't
work, right? there it did update but it
doesn't tell me. Um, so just make sure
it is running inside the chat if you
want to make sure, right? And if it's
struggling, all you do, I've done this
before, if it breaks, is like you copy
the URL over here, you go back to open
claw, you paste it in the chat, and you
say update to this version. Right? So
that's how to update, how to fix things.
If you see any bugs or errors like I've
just seen, then you can fix it quickly
using this method. If you go back to
OpenClaw and the updates now, the other
thing is native PDF tools. So your AI
can now read your documents. So what
changed is basically open core now has a
built-in PDF tool that lets your AI
assistant read, analyze and work with
PDFs and then the supported AI providers
include anthropic and Google with
automatic fallback for other AI models.
What this means is basically like you
can upload a PDF, the AI can read and
summarize it. You know, you can drop in
like a research paper, the AI answers
questions about it. You can send a
client proposal, the AI helps you
actually edit it as well. And there are
configurable limits which mean you can
control how large a PDF can be, when you
upload it, how many pages get processed
and which AI model handles the reading.
Right? The next one, openclaw config
validate. Right? So you can stop
breaking things before they break if
that makes sense. So this is quite an
interesting one. What changed is there a
brand new command. It's called openclaw
config validate. Right? And what it does
is before you start up your entire
openclaw setup, you can now check if
your set settings are correct first.
Right? So basically it's like a spell
checker but for your AI configuration on
open core. It can catch errors before
they cause problems. Now this is useful
for you because like one typo in a
config file uh used to mean like hours
of troubleshooting and I think we've all
been there with openclaw. Now you can
run one command and it tells you exactly
what's wrong and where, right? And you
can even run openclaw validate JSON to
get a clean structured error report.
There's some other cool stuff as well.
So for example, one of the most popular
messaging apps in Vietnam, Zalo, used by
over 70 million people, is now added
inside OpenClaw 2. And there's 100
security fixes. You can see a list of
all of them right here. Some other cool
stuff that didn't make the big headline.
So this is the big headline inside the
tweet in terms of what came in. But if
we go back to the updates, some other
stuff worth knowing. So you can use
locally hosted AI for memory search. Now
with OAMA, you can attach files when
spawning sub agents. You can reload the
config. You get transcripts of what the
AI agent actually heard if you want
that. You can do Docker health checks,
which means you can just check um if
your Docker if you're running it via
Docker, you can check if it's healthy or
not, right? Um and then you got funny
startup messages as well. So, it's
called a plug-in banner taglines. And
basically, this means when it starts up,
um it it gives you funny messages.
That's essentially it. So, this is
basically how it works. And you you know
you might be wondering okay who is this
update for so let me talk you through
that right so if you're a business owner
then the PDF tool and the telegram
updates are going to give you like
better customerf facing a bots right if
you're an e-commerce seller then multi-
aent ACP coordination automates more of
your workflows if you're a content
creator the telegram uh updates with
live messages just makes AI interactions
feel more natural for you and your
audience especially if you're showing
this stuff and then it can also use
alarm memory and it's got more security
patches as well. If you're based in
Vietnam, obviously it's using Zalo now.
And if you're just an AI hobbyist, then
there's 100 extra fixes, which means
things actually work better now. And
that's basically it. So that's how to
update. That's how to use it. You can
see it's working quite nicely here.
Pretty easy to set up. Even for example,
we uh updated the CLI as well directly
using this too. And you can now use ACP
agents. So just to recap, the too long
didn't read. Open Claw is a free tool
that connects AI models to messaging
apps and automates workflows. Version
the 2nd of March is one of the biggest
updates yet. The six big headline
features are Telegram live messages, ACP
sub agents on by default, native PDF
tool, the config validator, uh ZLO
plug-in, and 100 security fixes. If
you're struggling, um you know how to
fix it as you've seen today. If you've
seen any issues, and if you're new, this
is one of the best free automation tools
available right now. And this update
just makes it better, right? And the
other thing I would say here is like
they seem to be prioritizing security in
each of these updates. That's basically
how to get OpenClaw, how to use it, how
to set it up. If you want all the links,
we've got it inside the video notes
inside the air profit board today. This
also comes with a 6-h hour master class
on OpenClaw and another 3-hour one, as
you can see right here with full courses
and setup guides and everything else and
all the best use cases. We're constantly
updating this community with all the new
updates. You can see we've actually
added 1 2 3 uh six updates today on um
the newest updates. Yesterday we covered
mission control for openclaw, how to use
openclaw with uh clawed code as well.
We've also got other stuff on like
openclaw versus alternatives like
accomplish. I've pretty much tested like
all the big alternatives to openclaw. Um
that's basically how to use it. Now, if
you want to check this out, this is the
AI profit boardroom link in the comments
description or just go to the
aiprofitboardroom.com.
And if you want to learn how to save
time, scale, and grow with AI
automation. This one of the best places
inside the community. You'll get access
to 2,500 entrepreneurs who are doing
similar things as you, you get a daily
accountability group, so you can check
in, post your goals, and stay 100%
focused. You can ask questions and get
help and support inside the community,
too. And I also post weekly updates,
right? So, I actually tell you what's
worth paying attention to, what to
ignore. As you can see right here, we
added a new weekly update today. I
usually spend about 60 hours testing
this stuff each week. And so, like, I
just condense that down into like here's
the stuff to to figure out. Here's the
stuff you should try, like top three
things, and then here's all the other
stuff you can ignore. And if you're
wondering, okay, like are people getting
results with stuff like this? You
actually see we have over 133 pages of
wins from happy people inside our school
communities. So, you can see all the
wins, all people getting results with
this stuff. It's pretty much an infinite
scroll, as you can see right here. just
loads of people getting awesome results,
which is great to see. Inside the
community as well, you get four weekly
coaching calls. You can jump on these
video coaching calls, get help, get
support whenever you need to. You can
meet people in your local area. Just
zoom into the area that you want. And
then also inside the classroom, you can
see that we have a fiveweek master class
that takes you from beginner to expert
with AI automation and teaches you how
to build your first AI agent in under 5
minutes. Additionally, you'll learn all
of my best playbooks I personally run
for my business. So for example like AI
avatar videos, shorts, Instagram
newsletters, X and everything else. We
also have a full course for agencies. So
if you want to learn how to get more
clients, you can check that out here. If
you want to get the latest updates, just
check out this section. You can see we
update it every day with the most
important updates. And then if you want
to watch about the coaching course, you
can do that over here. If you want to
learn how to rank one with AI SEO, you
can check that out. And also, if you
want to learn how to grow a YouTube
channel based on what's working for me
with AI, there's a training on that,
too. So let's just check out the
questions. I think we got one more from
Naim who says how to get Kim K 2.5 for
free or the Miniax 2.5 right so there's
a few different ways let me I want to
talk to you but so what I would say one
of the easiest ways you can do this
right is you can actually go to
um in inside the onboarding for openclaw
you can select miniax right and if you
do the oorthth then you automatically
get opted in for three uh seven days for
free as a um free trial for miniax
coding, right? So, if you select miniax
on the on boarding for openclaw, then
you get 7 days test out miniax for free
with openclaw directly, right?
Automatically um subscribes you to the
coding plan. So, that's one option. The
other option is if you want to get Kim K
2.5 for free, you can do that with OAM,
right? So, you can check out Kimik 2.5
on Lama. We actually have full guides on
both of these things as well as GLM 4.7
flash. So, if you type in inside the air
profit board, if you type in the search
bar GLM 4.7, then you can see how to set
it up inside this tutorial, which is a
full video guide plus a step-by-step
process that talks you through it.
Right? If you want to learn how to set
up Kim K 2.5 with free, then you can
check out this video guide and the full
setup instructions right there. So,
whichever setup you prefer is waiting
inside there for you. And then also if
you want to check out how to set up
Miniax M2.5 then you can check this out
directly inside here as well. So we talk
you through exactly how to set that up
with a video tutorial and a full guide
as you can see. So if you go inside the
classroom here and then you go to SOP
updates, we have a full video tutorial
on null claw. We set it up, we tested
it, we we created a 30-day road map for
it and also 100 prompts on how to use
it, right? So, if you want to check that
out, that's inside here, as you can